the One Piece manga just revealed that
Luffy's grandfather Monkey D GARP is
setting out on a rogue mission to get
back Luffy's Marine friend Kobe from
Blackbeard and not only does this
basically confirm that GARP might be
part of the top secret Marine
organization sword but it also sets up a
major battle between Garb and the
Blackbeard Pirates now that may sound a
little bit crazy but Oda just dropped
this bombshell of his statement at a
Shonen Jump event just last week he said
this regarding the future of the manga
these two people will be fighting I
would call it a battle royale and I just
hope that no one dies and isn't that
just the perfect timing right there GARP
vs Blackbeard that's without any doubt
one of the most unexpected plot twists
that Oda has thrown into the story just
recently especially right after he
revealed that kizaru is coming to eckat
island with an entire Armada of marine
warships to stop Luffy and the straw
hats from taking vegapunk and speaking
of that we actually got a crazy update
on that situation as well well very
quickly because we see GARP arguing with
another Marine vice admiral that he
needs more forces to take back Kobe from
blackbeards however apparently the
Marines entire force has been ordered to
sail to eckhead Island together with
kizeru in other words the world
government is throwing everything they
have at the disposal right now at Luffy
when you think about it there are two
good reasons for this one Luffy is about
to take Dr vegapunk with him however the
government wants to kill vegapunk
because of everything he knows about
about century and the ancient Kingdom
and also because he's able to command
the seraphim the new deadly weapons that
he just created for the governments and
number two because the guru say no that
Luffy has eaten the legendary sun god
Nika fruit that they try to erase from
history and that they were desperate to
get their hands on for centuries and so
this is now their attempt to defeat
Luffy once and for all while he still
hasn't fully figured out his new powers
in other words the world government
including the five elders and emu the
secret ruler of the world have now all
fully acknowledged Luffy as a yonko you
know other than Rob Lucci who in this
chapter says he won't acknowledge Luffy
even though he was knocked out by a
Luffy in sunglasses without by the way
Landing so much as a single hit on him
that is some Next Level copium right
there but then again I don't mind seeing
Luchi getting his butt kicked a third
time by Luffy so win-win I'd say but
let's go back to GARP now so while
Akainu has sent kizeru and all these
warships and Fighters the Marines had
stationed new worlds to take out Luffy
GARP is now going on a rogue and clearly
unauthorized mission to save Kobe from
blackbeards why is that well in case you
need a quick refresher in chapter 7 Kobe
was able to join the Marines after Luffy
saved Zorro and the remaining Marine
soldiers from the tyrannical rule of X
and Morgan Kobe was also accompanied by
Morrigan sanhelmeppo who was the one who
by the way blackmailed and almost killed
Zorro in the first place and so after
they joined the Marines for some still
unknown reason Kobe and helmeppo are
then personally trained by Luffy's
grandfather GARP turning both of them
into quite powerful fighters in a very
short amount of time teaching them both
hockey and the techniques of the six
powers that are also being used by Rob
Lucian Co so uh yeah we do know that
Kobe is a very important student for
garb that he cares about but I think
there is a lot more to this I mean why
would Garba risk confronting a yonko
right now for a single Marine Soldier no
matter how close they really are and how
did the Marines learn about Kobe's
capture in the first place while the
elephant in the room right here is of
course sword a secret organization
within the Marines that works
independently of the celestial dragons
and the gurosei basically this group
wants to turn the Marines into a true
Force for the good of the people and not
just a tool to keep the world Nobles in
power so they can live in glamor and
terrorize the people of the world now we
do know for a fact that Kobe helmeppo
and X Drake were all part of this
organization Drake for instance was sent
to spy on kaido as part of his crew and
now just recently in chapter 1061 we met
another Marine Commander called hebari
another sword member who is really
worried about Kobe and who tried to
convince a few other sword members to go
rescue him and now this very same hibari
and helmepo are being picked up by Garb
to go and save Kobe from beehive Islands
now I'm obviously not the first person
to speculate that Garb might be part of
or even be the leader of Swords after
all he more than openly stated a couple
of times that he hated the celestial
dragons and that he refused a promotion
to Admiral multiple times to avoid being
under their direct control when I think
about it GARP is pretty much the perfect
example of what you would call a good
Marine someone who truly wants to help
and protect the people from both Pirates
and corrupt government of officials
alike so he would undoubtedly be a more
than perfect fit for this organization
and the fact that he trained so many of
sword's current members makes it really
unlikely I'd say that he has nothing to
do with the entire thing at all on top
of all that he's about to attack beehive
Island and the Blackbeard Pirates and
will you look at that there are two
people with Blackbeard right now that
are also theorized to be secret sword
members one of them is former Marine
Admiral aokiji who has joined the
Blackbeard Pirates after his duel with a
kainu now I've already talked in depth
about aokiji's motives in this video
right here where I explained all of the
Blackbeard Pirates and it is pretty
obvious that aokiji is just spying on
Blackbeard to keep an eye on him but
taking this a step further many people
believe that aokiji is actually also a
part of swordtube just like x-drake has
been sent to infiltrate the crew of a
yonko and who is the second person you
ask well last time we actually saw
Blackbeard he was attacking none other
than Luffy's Ally Law and there is an
absolutely fantastic Theory by my fellow
YouTuber Randy Troy that goes into depth
about all the evidence and hints that
law has been an undercover Marine all
along actually if you'd like to see an
in-depth video about all that make sure
to subscribe and let me know in the
comments if we get let's say 2 000
subscribers until tomorrow I'm sure we
can make something happen what is really
suspicious though is that all of these
potential sword members have been in
contact with each other law and aokiji
both suspiciously arrived at Punk Hazard
at the exact same time law and Kobe were
the two main characters in The Rocky
Port incident that Blackbeard knew about
as well Drake frees law from the prison
in wano and then talks to Kobe right
after and aokiji was of course a big fan
and student of GARP when he was still
younger and the list goes on and on and
on what I'm trying to get at here is
that Oda is setting up a war between the
Blackbeard Pirates and a rogue part of
the Marines swords and even though GARP
is clearly not getting any sort of
backup from the main Marine Forest that
is sailing towards Luffy he will not be
fighting alone this war will most likely
involve all of the sword members that we
know officially so far and I assume we
will also see a whole bunch of new sword
members revealed as well on top of that
since we have La Kobe and Blackbeard all
in one spot I'm also expecting a
flashback about the rocky Port incident
and maybe even about the history of
Sword itself and I also expect aokiji to
play a decisive role here in helping
Kobe and hopefully law Escape as well
now to be fair so far we don't actually
know if law and Blackbeard will be at
beehive Island for sure when GARP
arrives there with the members of sort
after all last time we saw them they
were still fighting but based on
everything we've discussed so far it
would be really strange if GARP and
Blackbeard wouldn't Clash after all of
this and so the question right now of
course is whether or not GARP has a
chance to win this thing I mean we all
know that Blackbeard has long been set
up as Luffy's main rival in the chase
for the one piece so similar to law the
chances of Garb actually defeating
Blackbeard seem fairly slim simply based
on the fact that the structure of the
story seems to suggest a battle between
Luffy and blackbeards now that being
said though GARP has been set up to be
one of the strongest Marines all
throughout the story Who has fought on a
level with the likes of rocks Roger
Whitebeard and Shiki we also saw that
Rayleigh was able to at least scare
Blackbeard off and I would think that
Garb would be at least a strong Israeli
if not stronger than him and so should
GARP and Blackbeard actually fight then
I would expect it to be one of the best
fights we've seen in the entire story so
far given that Oda doesn't off screen
most of it again as he really likes to
do with these types of fights and uh
seeing guard fighting at full strength
is something that I have been wishing
for for a long long time and I'm sure he
could leave quite the impact on
blackbeards however should that quote
from Oda about the unexpected battle
actually turn out to be about this
specific fight I think GARP has a pretty
big death Flack above his head and uh
let's be real GARP dying at the hands of
Blackbeard would be an even more
traumatic experience for us than Ace's
death was I mean GARP has been one of
the most beloved and respected
characters among fans and it would be
another incredibly traumatic event for
Luffy as well of course when you think
about it GARP was basically his father
figure during his childhood since Dragon
was never around for him so the person
who trained him and was the only part of
his family that actually was there for
him was GARP and I'm very curious how
all of this will be playing out but
there was a bunch of other major things
happening in this chapter as well that
we need to talk about too one thing for
instance is that Oda basically confirmed
that there is both an unexpected Ally
but also an unexpected Trader on Egghead
Island right now because even though
vegapunk had locked up the top of the
egg Dome so even the seraphim wouldn't
be able to enter it someone has helped
zp0 opening the dome for them and so now
they are able to once again chase after
vegapunk and the straw hats now my
personal main suspect here would be
Lilith who seems to have been very
pro-government and very anti-strawheads
all along but who knows maybe it was
someone else in the meantime vegapunk
has contacted a mysterious character who
apparently is strong enough to help them
fight off the seraphim and Luchi I am
more than intrigued by this is it
someone that we already know or a new
character my brain always keeps jumping
to scopper Gabon for some reason when it
comes to to these types of mysterious
strong characters but we'll have to see
and seeing Zorro play with Kaku will be
a real pleasure to follow as well I'm
actually really curious to see if Zara
will have any side effects from having
seen that Grim Reaper in wano or not and
whether Kaku will have an awakened
giraffe devil fruit and what that would
look like but the other real Banger in
this chapter was of course kit killer
and the rest of the crew arriving at
elbaf because this has some very
interesting implications as we now know
the mysterious man with the burning
marks that kid talked about in wano is
Robin's friend Saul who retrieved all
the books from the library of O'Hara and
brought it to elbaf and according to Kit
he knows about the last Road poneglyph
and that makes a lot of sense when you
think about it because it really
wouldn't be that big of surprise if the
Librarians of O'Hara had somehow gotten
their hands on a road Pony glyph now
that would of course give kid a major
Head Start in the race for love tale
however as you might know I'm also a big
believer in the theory that elbaf is
part of shanks's territory and under his
rule which would be pretty fitting law
vs Blackbeard and Kid vs Shanks there
are actually a lot of reasons why Shanks
is most likely on elbaf and why the
straw hats will have to go there next as
well if you're curious go check out that
video right here thank you so much for
watching my videos in 2022 and I hope to
see you around next year as well let me
know what you want to see on the channel